we did it we finally did it
we broke the world record kids live
stream of fortnight has hundred thousand
more live viewers then all of war
tonight on twitch right now making him
the biggest four nights three yes let
this be an inspirational message for all
of you the biggest four night streamer I
can use this to every brand I ever work
with hey you know biggest sport night
streamer for at night I'm the greatest
for tonight's streamer let it be known
hey Brad let's prank Felix and make his
voice higher pitch for the rest of the
video Felix you saw nothing just keep
scrolling okay great I have a feeling
this week it's mostly gonna be Elon Musk
memes damn I gotta say though I'm more
of a : Isaac Mars guy damn that : Isaac
Mars girl looks hot
there we go everyone hosting meme review
just for the means gaining the support
of eighty-three potential customer 83
million potential customers
Tesla Chuck rice to 300% this is what we
need to show people ones
Elon Musk host meme review everyone has
to buy a Tesla alright
you understand all in favor I'm having
mr. BAE's toast meme review say aye
ah normal billionaires done oh god it
keeps going watch I see we go home for
YouTube's favorite show everybody meme
review that's right welcome um those
dead eyes swimming alright I've seen
this one I sent it to Brad he was very
thrilled about it he was laughing at his
own jokes
Brad one laughing at fuse jokes nothing
has ever been more legit what do you
mean Brad what what the Frick is that
supposed to mean
top stories man gets cancer on cancerous
growth killing the growth and ending his
cancer
it hurts its topic
a girl made a sign language cover so
deaf people can close the gap this is
what I'm talking about
at this point we have 83 million
subscribers we need to branch out we
need to go to places unknown before
listen I didn't want to do this but I
got to tell you
PewDiePie has closed captions on Paula's
videos so the deaf community can watch
that's true actually hey does that work
I don't know anything about sign
language I know that one that's pretty
cool thank you very much Roselle bad bud
for doing your part I promise I made my
computer write about 20 hours doctor
bailed on your pillow top
everybody get punished dr. Phil time to
send them to the rains I think I need
help send me to the ranch paws are
buying Jeep Wow dr. Phil got a GPO
sponsorship
70 million go home name review it's time
for YouTube's favorite show everybody
meme review makes me so uncomfortable
dr. Phil oh god it keeps going in
Spanish it's me well then well done that
is horrifying
this is beyond science how many nine
year olds are there in the world eighty
two point seventy nine million what
who's not nine who's actually not nine
huh I know you're out there
show yourself goddamnit oh yeah Ellen's
never coming on suicide rate jumps two
hundred percent just kidding
he will definitely come on suicide rates
jump two hundred okay watching the Super
Bowl for the game itself watching the
Super Bowl for my roof I watching that
for the commercials watching for the
sweet victory at halftime watching for
the PTP I had did you guys actually see
it live when sicko mode started playing
instead of sweet victory so I didn't
understand what this was about but
apparently there was a petition for
sponge fun look at that 1.2 million
people sign it to have a sweet victory
performed at the Super Bowl and they
started off making it seem like it was
gonna happen but instead they just cut
to in Travis Scott
[Music]
I would have been so epic miss King
companies can't get anything right you
get it you put it right in front of them
right in front of their faces going like
hey this is a brilliant idea
just take it just go with it that's all
you got to do I see what you're doing
here but we're gonna add maroon 5 in
instead people love maroon 5 right final
attempt to get to the wire well you're
dead it boy or girl I don't know that's
pretty goddamn ethnic please get on your
dad's Twitter and ask everyone to
subscribe - PewDiePie is he 9 is Baron
Trump 9 alright well we tried
what if Elin musk bought a Super Bowl ad
screening name review live well we know
they didn't have a him okay yeah so this
is what happened you guys should check
out mr. B's video so apparently they try
I knew about this he told me but they
were gonna try to get blankets in
because you're not allowed to obstruct
the view but they they took them away
but instead they figured out they could
use where the t-shirts I thought it was
brilliant like the photo that came out
of it is so legendary seriously even my
mom wrote me about it guys like this was
posted by ESPN how cool is that
mr. B's at this point is this doing his
part a hundred times over this is what
I'm talking about
we never stop we never surrender
I left my computer running for two
months to put Gloria Borger space on
pity pipe whoa
how the Frick did you do that that looks
so accurate when they play sicker mode
instead of sweet victory it's gonna be
weird repetition listen you know what
mr. B deserves I agree okay don't worry
I already terrorized Charlotte wait
petition to get Felix on hot ones I
would love to I love spicy food but I
also hate traveling so there you go
there's some there's a dial on my okay
yeah along sign let's make it this
happen let's make every one of these
tests list automatically subscribe to
commute apart what a great idea
na
z TV and other indian channels i think
look how the massacred my boy markiplier
has fallen this is what I'm talking soda
music India jacksepticeye has fallen
we're losing the fights they're picking
up our Ella generals what's next they'll
come from mr. B's I thought it was super
dope this is a problem when you heiped
stuff up people are who are gonna get
disappointed what you expected them to
actually buy a five million dollar
Superbowl ad like are you kidding me
oh it's been five million dollars woohoo
like Jesus Christ dude okay
two nine year olds advertising kids at a
cricket game in Australia beautiful like
he could barely see it amazing well done
lads
well done petition for Papa Gloria to
include bonus overseas in penis of
course I'll have a chat with the
department a hit
remember the sub gap this is him now
feel old yet goddamnit where we actually
that far ahead
ah kids and God oh no they figured out
they're holding me accountable for what
I say again I'm not gonna plea for
tonight what do you think I'm some
pathetic betameche clean-shaven as well
oh how the mighty has fallen what did it
cost everything everything can we get a
minute of silence for the old now to
monetize heroes of the YouTube golden
era well I so sad who's more likely to
suck penis to save YouTube channel
everyone picked themselves well here we
are
listen desperate times calls for
desperate measure mints I did what I had
to do and I'm not proud of it goddammit
what is this can the prince is PewDiePie
the PT sir do you have magic hair of
course magic
nobody cats do animals talk to you were
you poison
oh I definitely was I was horrible
kidnapped or enslaved yes do people
assume all your problems get sold
because a big strong man she is a
princess thank you guys I've been saying
this literally for years get jack black
to plate with lasagna on a saxophone one
person has signage that's a Chaplinsky
you got to do what I'm sorry Louie
goddammit felix has said he's sending me
through the range just saying no you and
he has to go good guys don't tell her
that
come on there it is modern problems
Marta solutions guys do you not
understand 4:9 is a family friendly game
if I'm the biggest family-friendly
youtuber for tonight's streamers this
changes the game all right
found this on Twitter this is so good I
don't like your cheese serese nothing
personal kid gone whichever will it be
settle down t-series I'm here just built
a real team you're trying to deter me
from spot on number one but you in the
year you lose so much things you haven't
won when after we do we're gonna be
complete
[Music]
well dad my fellow nine-year-olds thank
you very much me waiting for Elon Musk
meme review I'm right there with you
guys
I understand but in Sweden we say then
some vent Apollo got went around it I'll
take Blaney I don't know the expression
actually but you know what I'm saying
right
you know you understand for tonight
really is all you need to beat the
algorithm there you go
number one on trending oopsie how did
that happen Wow
I'm a 2-0 deaf school sure I want to
send a feeling to help me get into also
there's a video of it if you want to see
how I made damn that looks legit 0 Dec
so far from T series at least took me
five dates I like I returned it I like
it to art by zelma I'm very nice thank
you very much at 84 million I'll play
this game again guys we need her I never
said this but it is time this series is
getting too close huh
it's test you may not like it but this
is what peak performance looked like
don't get jealous now YouTube don't get
jealous and do monetize the video plea
pie cosplay fish lasagna online to being
comic-con oh my god
it actually looks like
my god okay thank you everyone for doing
their part these are dark times but if
we keep working together we can pull
through maybe at some point t-series
will just give up okay that's that's
pretty much our only strategy if we're
hang on long enough maybe they'll just
give up and delete their channel and
realize that's the idea let's hope it
works out I'd say for me for now thank
you guys so much for all the love and
support
honestly it means so much for me thank
you and I said that was way too lame
okay I don't like you guys all right
Betty there you go
you want pyramids we got them
oh you're into casos huh we got you
covered baby you want some bets easy we
got it all this game is still relevant
god dammit
[Music]